as greetings go this is as big as it
gets in Germany the Brandenburg gate
where East and West were once divided
now a monument to Unity and a moment to
rekindle International friendships the
king and the German president shoulder
to shoulder
no other head of state has been given a
ceremonial welcome here the highest of
honors for the King's first state visit
and a moment to remember for berliners
that the first country is Germany it's
an obvious sign because of the really
good bond between these countries before
the coronation which shows the good
relationship between the two countries
which I really appreciate this visit is
all about rebuilding relations after
years of brexit turbulence a royal
deployment of sensitive diplomacy
although this trip was supposed to start
in France there is a poignant symmetry
with Germany being the King's first
state visit it's here in Berlin where
the queen started her last back in 2015.
[Music]
she was famed for her Ballroom diplomacy
echoed here at the Bellevue palace with
the king and queen consort guests of
honor at estate banquet the relationship
between
Germany and the United Kingdom matters
greatly to me too
president
but behind the pleasantries from the
president a much blunter message
today is the 29th of March on this very
day six years ago the British government
submitted its application to leave the
European Union I'll say it quite frankly
for me personally this was a sad day
this is the soft power of the monarchy
in full motion and with war in Europe a
chance to strengthen ever important
alliances Laura bundock Sky News in
Berlin